at was the gift that came from the
heavens for me I was in Tunisia making
Raiders of the Lost Ark and we were
setting up a shot and I was picking up
fossils in the desert which used to be
the bottom of the ocean millions of
years ago and we were out there in the
nefta desert I was picking up uh and I
was remembering the end of Close
Encounters when Richard Dreyfuss goes up
into the mothership and just before that
the little alien comes down and does the
hand signs to Francois truffo
and it just hit me out of the sky I
thought what if the alien has stayed
behind on Earth
what if he didn't whatever it was a kind
of Foreign Exchange Dreyfus goes away
and the alien stays and it's suddenly
this whole story hit me like a ton of
bricks and which was really a story
about my mom and dad when they got
divorced and how I felt as a kid wanting
a friend like that to fill the void in
my life and and and all these things
came pouring in and I actually put the
story together in a couple of
I think a couple of days